so in code vlogs devlog eight
i talked about how i was playing around
with unreal and i had a few games in
mind
and
i said in this video
that if it got
at least 20 likes
i would make a video talking about the
game extended stay as it exists in my
mind and lo and behold
the video got 22 likes
one for me
it counts i think
but anyway
i guess i'm obligated to make a video
about
extended stay
the game
i should start out by saying that this
idea
is not really fleshed out
i've talked about it to one friend
i've thought about it a lot
but i've never
i haven't like fully designed it but
here's what i have in mind here's what i
think would be really fun this is all
just based off of
something that i would like to play and
i don't think is entirely out there
although
pieces of it are out there because
naturally
this kind of accommodates its
accumulates i don't know one of those
words a bunch of games that i like and
kind of puts it into a new setting
so i'm going to reference a lot of other
games and mention mechanics in those
games that i think would
be really fun in this type of game so i
play a good bit of this game called
seven days to die and i've done a few
series on my gaming channel about it
and i really like it it's really fun
so in this series
i
just basically tried to survive in a
wasteland
and this is a vauxhall game and i think
box games are really fun
in general
so that's something i would want in this
type of game just having a destructible
world and something you can like
you know even if you don't want to you
know dig tunnels everywhere because
it'll take forever you know that you
could if you wanted to and that sort of
thing is really cool
to know you can do in a game so
naturally that's got to come over
uh of course this is
i bring up seven days to die rather than
minecraft although of course minecraft
is very similar
because uh well i would also i think the
setting of this game i'm talking about
would work way better in a more
real
world not not a cartoony minecraft type
box okay
so i'm thinking of a system
that uh
not exactly like theirs but on seven
days to die but inspired for sure i hear
you that doesn't tell us crap i know i
realize it doesn't all right well
okay think seven days to die but instead
of zombies
you have
something that's staying a little too
long
aliens
hence extended stay
so
the starting point
would be something like either you start
out with full civilization something
happens very quickly like most people
get abducted and there's only a few left
or something like that but you could put
it in a pvp open world
and occasionally these alias would show
up and try to abduct people
and
maybe it takes them hundreds even
thousands of years to complete their
abductions and they're kind of just like
harvesting slowly so they just show up
every once in a while and like raid
and you got to survive that when they do
show up so it gives it kind of a clock
of okay i've got a few days before i
know they're gonna show up again and be
wanting us for whatever the heck they do
with us
and then it could go anywhere from there
like are they abducting people and
who knows eating them
turning them into something else are
they taking somewhere else making a new
civilization or a new colony on another
planet with humans who knows that the
possibilities are endless
but really it would be about the
struggle of the people who are still in
the world and trying to like find a way
to have the humans win over the aliens
and this whole idea
comes from a game i loved when i was a
kid that i played in the 90s a lot and
that game
is
xcom
this is a
rebuild of it called openxcon it fixes a
bunch of bugs and adds a bunch of
improvements but the original xcom i
believe it came out 1995. this game
was a fight for the world to win in the
against the aliens who were trying
to i don't know what they were doing
take over the world basically
so this would be similar in that fashion
just
open world survival x-cop so you could
think of mesh in the two and i don't
want people to confuse this with the the
newer xcoms the newer xcoms but they
don't have anywhere close to like the
worldly feel of com
ufo defense
like your planets actually die
like those the new ones just feel fun
and like you're going on an adventure
basically the old one this old 1995 one
it was a survival game and it was it's
fun it's very hard maybe i'll do a let's
play but sometimes i think it got my
programmer might kind of tuned right at
a very early age because i was playing
this when i was like
i don't even know i want to say like
nine or ten or something and
do i have a game going on no i don't
well
maybe i'll start a quick one alien
defense base
okay so you have a world you make a base
and
i can't i don't know if i can if i full
screen this i think it's going to mess
up the recording so
and
you know you have all your base
management and you have soldiers you go
on little missions you shoot down
ships and you research their technology
and after a long long long time of
playing this and surviving well the
aliens get harder over time and you find
more of them and it just gets crazier
and there's just more stuff when you say
when you think you've seen everything in
this game
more stuff happens that you're like whoa
man this is detailed like
when you do research
there's not much to start but once you
start picking up alien items
you can research them just like so much
detail goes into this stuff
it's crazy
ufopedia here
so
for every item in the game
there are details on it and some things
just have write-ups on them like the
alien bodies they don't have any stats
but
when you research an alien
you find out a bunch about it and you
learn sometimes its weaknesses and stuff
and if you can capture live aliens you
can
learn about
what ones of that rank do and learn even
more about them
and that actually ends up being
spoiler alert on how to beat this game
that ends up being how you beat this
game because as a kid i spent so many
hours doing all this because it was so
interesting
and eventually you research some of the
highest commander
rank uh
aliens
and you learn of their origins and where
their planet is and you go to their
planet
and you kill them and that's how you win
you go to their they their own base and
kill them but along the way so much
oh it's amazing like okay the aliens
will end up making base stations in the
world at some point and you've got to go
to those bases that they're setting up
on your world and raid them and take
them out and they keep happening they
overwhelm you this game is difficult
very difficult
and it's so hard to beat
it really really inspired me
it's also not for the faint of heart
like
you need a lot of patience to play this
game and beat it
this game it's a very slow grind it's
like it's like putting together a puzzle
i would want
my game to have that kind of same feel
but also
those are the main ideas there's a lot
more little stuff here and there
that i thought about and obviously i
want to come up with my own unique take
on all this i don't want to copy
but those are like the two main
inspirations that were in my head when i
originally thought of this